les missions locales font partie
intégrante du service public de l'emploi
pour les jeunes de 16 à 25 ans elle
accueille chaque année environ un
million trois cent mille jeunes au
niveau national à l'heure actuelle nous
constatons une multiplicité multiplicité
des initiatives de toute part logique de
bassin fusion baisse des subventions de
fonctionnement financement via des
appels à projets mise en place d'un
bonus malus et cela sans concertation
avec le réseau des missions locales qui
dans les territoires sont des acteurs
indispensables pour l'emploi de nos
jeunes
en dépit de la diversité du public
accueilli pour certains déjà exclu de
tout autre dispositif aux structures
ce sont plus d'un million de situations
professionnelles qui ont été mobilisés
pour les jeunes par les missions locales
dont 540 4000 contrats de travail + 3 %
en un an
quarante mille contrats en alternance +
8 %
seize mille retour en formation + 7 %
les missions locales doivent leur
réussite à un accompagnement global et
personnalisée du public concerné et à
une expertise de leur territoire et de
son contexte économique
mais n'oublions pas n'oublions pas que
les missions locales ce sont également
des équipes dont l'inquiétude s'accroît
en raison d'une absence de lisibilité de
leur devenir
ce manque de confiance dans leur avenir
créer une tension sociale dans le réseau
monsieur le ministre monsieur le
ministre
quelles sont les intentions du
gouvernement concernant le devenir des
missions locales
avez-vous le souhait de consolider ses
structures pour les mettre au coeur de
la bataille pour l'emploi des jeunes
et si oui comment merci pour répondre ma
parole et homélies chargé des relations
avec le parlement que marc fesneau
vous avez la parole merci monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs madame la sénatrice voudrais
vous remercier d'avoir de votre question
qui me permet de mettre en lumière le
travail remarquable que font les
missions locales et de vous répondre sur
les points d'interrogation que vous avez
pu lever s'agissant donc des missions
locales la ministre du travail a eu
l'occasion de rappeler ici dans cet
hémicycle n'a jamais été question
c'était parfois une des inquiétudes qui
est élevé de fusionner de force les
missions locales avec les structures de
pôle emploi
certains élus nous ont demandés en
revanche comment mieux travailler
ensemble mieux partager les informations
voire prévoir des structures en commun
ce sont ces formes de coopérations
renforcées qu'il est possible
d'expérimenter qui doit venir du terrain
et que pour le coup nous encouragerons
par ailleurs un chantier important porte
sur les systèmes d'information
aujourd'hui les missions locales
fonctionnent bien mais reconnaissons le
les missions locales n'ont pas accès aux
offres d'emploi tandis que pôle emploi
n'a pas accès toujours aux données de
ses missions locales
l'intérêt général impose de parvenir à
des rapprochements de travailler plus
étroitement même si chacun doit rester
évidemment dans son rôle concernant le
financement le ministère du travail
participe au budget des missions locales
à hauteur de la moitié le reste est
financé par les collectivités
agglomération communauté de communes
départements ou régions nous souhaitons
aller vers une approche de résultats
aujourd'hui une subvention dont le
fonctionnement est par ailleurs
l'activité de garantie jeunes
la notion de résultat n'est pas lié à la
dépense de fonctionnement nous voulons
donc une partie la suivant ce soit les
aux résultats tout le monde a des
objectifs à respecter en particulier
je suis sûr que nous partagerons quand
il s'agit d'argent public nous
conservons la même enveloppe avec une
diminution de 2% qui et absorbable
notamment avec les questions numériques
enfin les missions locales doivent
davantage orienter les jeunes vers
l'ensemble des dispositifs certaines le
font ils sont d'ailleurs très innovante
en ce domaine jours s ituée le cas du
havre et en particulier cité le travail
qui a été fait
merci des applaudissements et salue au
passage le travail qui a été fait par la
sénatrice canayer qui a été président de
cette mission locale et le travail
remarquable qui a été fait par cette
liste comme quoi parfois on peut
partager des choses d'autres privilégiés
l'orientation des jeunes vers la
garantie jeunes car elle était financée
sur ce dispositif nous souhaitons donc
qu'elle aille au devant des jeunes
qu'elle des troupes dans les villages
dans les zones rurales au pied si je
veux dire des tours et dans les
quartiers et travaille davantage avec
les acteurs de l'insertion meilleure
synergie meilleur échange d'informations
encouragements résultats voilà le sens
que voulons donner à la politique et le
changer la place que nous voulons donner
aux missions locales bloc de chirac pour
quelques secondes
monsieur le ministre je vous remercie
pour votre tentative de réponse qui est
tout à fait théorique et nous
l'entendons nous connaissons cette
réponse là toutefois nous vous invitons
à venir voir dans nos territoires
comment se passe la réalité des liens et
les succès des missions locales qui sont
des petites structures fragiles
soutenez-le est un tout petit peu plus
que parle de simplement merci beaucoup